so we had a we had a false alarm
yesterday my wife my wife is gonna give
birth and any day now she'll give birth
and and yesterday shortly after the show
actually we well she was talking to the
doctors and and based on what she said
they they said you got to go to the
hospital
it might be time and so we go to the
hospital we're there for six for six
hours maybe more and then they send us
home because they say it's not time yet
false alarm which means that you know
maybe there's a chance now that I'll get
to deliver a baby in the car on the way
to the hospital and so that's exciting
but the point is on the way to the
hospital this time I happen to mention
and you have to understand the context
I'm not gonna get into all of it but I
happen to mention on the way that you
know there there really isn't anywhere
comfortable for me to sleep in the labor
and delivery room I just I happen to
mention that you know and and and that's
a problem I think I think I think that
they should make these rooms a little
bit more comfortable for the men that's
all I'm saying that's it and my wife
reacts like there's something wrong with
making this observation on the way to
the hospital and then she says and this
floored me
okay this floored me and it's one of
those moments where you stop and you
think who is this person that I married
she said I'm not kidding she said well
when you can give birth then you'll get
your own bed excuse me excuse me when I
can give birth I can give birth any time
I please I could give birth every day if
I wanted okay this is the year 2019
don't try to put me in your gendered box
don't you sit there don't you dare sit
there and impose these social constructs
on me how dare you how dare you and then
I broke down into tears and I called the
police and my wife called the divorce
lawyer I don't know why
fake stories always end on such a dark
note okay
what I really want to begin with is is
now that we've gotten that difficult
moment out of the way I regret to inform
you ladies and gentlemen that the
climate twerkers speaking of disturbing
the climate twerkers are added again
watch this yes the that's no this isn't
a replay this doesn't replay from Monday
this is this is they remember they shut
down DC the shut down DC climate
protesters they were in DC on Monday
doing this and and they're add they're
doing it again
it's Friday they're once again they're
back they're shutting down roads
blocking traffic because they didn't
tick off the entire city enough last
time and they weren't enough of a hassle
and they didn't do enough to prevent
people from getting to their jobs and
getting their kids to school so they
figured let's do it again
and they're also calling as it may not
surprise you they're calling for Trump's
impeachment did she just say I think I
heard did she just say we will not stand
for the destruction of the climate chaos
then she say that we will not stand for
the destruction of the climate chaos I'm
pretty sure she said that so so she's
saying that they don't want the climate
chaos to end they so they do want
climate chaos is that what this is all
about I'm confused but here's really my
point just look at look at one more
quick clip here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so here's my thing these
people were just and you saw there's a
lot of people there right now or this
morning anyway these these people were
they were protesting all day on Monday
and they were protesting the Friday
before that the Friday before that was a
climate walked out thing a lot of the
same people were involved I'm sure and
so they're Friday Monday and and now
they're back at it again on Friday
that's three days of protests three work
days of protests in the last week in the
last seven days three of them they've
sped out on the street holding signs so
how does that conversation go when you
call up your work on the third day how
do you it's like hi boss yeah I got I
got a call out of work again what yeah
for another protest yeah yeah uh-huh
yeah I know I missed the one I missed
work for a protest last week yeah I know
I missed for a week the week before that
I miss it too but but but you know the
thing is excuse me
what was it fired it's just okay I
realized the problem with that
hypothetical conversation is that it
assumes that these people have jobs in
the first place which which of course
they don't but they don't have jobs and
they're obviously not trying to get jobs
because this isn't what you do when you
have to get a job we'd have to get a job
yeah you should be hitting the pavement
but you should be doing that with your
khakis on and your shirt tucked in and
you know your resume in hand hitting the
pavement going into places shaking hands
that's what you should be doing you
shouldn't be wearing jorts in the street
torquing at least that's not how
did it back in my day and yet I
guarantee you I absolutely guarantee you
that every single one of those people
would tell you a tearful story about how
they can't they can't pay back their
student loans i guarante you know I'm
right if you go there and you talk to
those people and you say what's going on
with your student loans guys immediately
the violins they there's gonna be a
whole violin section it's gonna be like
a symphony orchestra of whining and
they're gonna tell you all about oh my
gosh I kid I've been struggling with
these loads that I just can't get a job
and I don't know what to do I just kid
I'm struggling guy you don't know my
pain you know you just don't understand
it they all want us to feel sorry for
them for their financial position even
as they spend their days holding poster
board and shouting slogans into micro
into megaphones and this is why this is
one of the reasons why it's not it's not
even that it's not the main reason I
mean the main reason why I don't I'm not
interested in paying back student loans
people student loans is that they're not
my loans not my responsibility sorry but
the second reason is I just don't
believe when I I'm sorry when I hear
these college graduates talking about
how they can't get a job and there's no
jobs I just don't I don't believe them I
gotta tell you I really don't believe it
because there are a lot of jobs out
there you just have to be you have to
number one be willing to do them and
number two you have to try to get them
so I you know I just I don't believe it
I'm sorry I think if you're a college
graduate you haven't had you you you
know you you haven't had a job in two
years it's because you're just really
not trying hard enough to get one but
Bernie will still tell us that these
poor helpless little puppy dogs need us
to bail them out it's their right to be
bailed out in fact Bernie sent out a
tweet last night and the tweet said
getting an education listen to this see
if you can make sense of this getting an
edgy
isn't a crime we need to cancel every
penny of student debt so that of course
is a total non sequitur that is what we
call a non sequitur and Bernie does this
all the time because he is a vapid silly
airhead of a man and this is what he do
he starts with a this is what he does he
starts with a a I just call him an
airhead and then I just follow that up
with the phrase this is what he do and
this is what he do this dummy um anyway
he starts with a general statement or
declaration and then and then he
concludes with a statement that has
nothing to do with the first thing he
said like okay yes getting an education
is not a crime we agree but why does
that mean we should cancel student debts
yet that you can't say getting an
education isn't a crime
therefore cancel debt there's an implied
therefore in between the two sentences
and that I don't see the connection if
getting an education was a crime then
there wouldn't be any student loan to
cancel in the first place because you
wouldn't be able to get one because the
the banks wouldn't be able to loan it
just like you can't it's a crime to be a
heroin dealer and you couldn't go into a
bank and say hey I need a loan I'm
starting this heroin business and I
really need ten thousand dollars to get
it going
couldn't do that so you might as well go
this statement from Bernie he might as
well go to subway and I actually have no
doubt that he would do something like
this go to Subway order a sandwich the
cashier says that'll be six-fifty and
then you say wait you want money eating
a sandwich is not a crime it makes no
sense speaking of making no sense and on
a somewhat related note here is
alexandria kzo cortez i mean what this
all is is us reaching into our pockets
and deciding how we're already spending
the money that we're already
contributing to society the problem is
that America is at its wealthiest point
that we've ever been and yet we've we
are at one of our most unequal points
that we've ever been you would not know
that our country is posting record
profits because 40 million Americans are
living in poverty right now and if the
poverty line was real if it was at
around what some people think it should
be about thirty eight thousand dollars a
year we will be shocked at how much the
richest society on the planet is is
allowing so much of its people to live
in destitute so we're not talking about
paying for somebody else we're talking
about getting our own rent under control
we're talking about not getting fleeced
by our own landlords
yes that's correct she wants to move the
poverty line to 38,000 dollars a year
that would be by the way about night
that's that's uh and I haven't done the
math actually but I correct me if I'm
wrong that would so if you're if you're
working full time on an on a an hourly
wage thirty eight thousand dollars a
year that would be like 18 or 19 bucks
an hour assuming you know forty hours a
week so now so now what nineteen dollars
an hour is poverty so we've gone from
let's raise the minimum wage to fifteen
to oh no actually nineteen dollars an
hour is destitute poverty destitution
she's a destitution destitution is close
to forty grand a year so if you're
making close to forty grand a year
you are destitute did you know that you
probably didn't know that because it
doesn't feel like you're destitute you
could be right now if you make forty
grand here especially if you're a single
person making forty grand a year you
could be you can be watching this right
now or listening to it on your phone in
your apartment that you pay for you got
your car that you pay for in the in the
parking lot downstairs if you got your
TV there you're on your couch you got a
frigerator full of food all of that that
you easily could pay for with thirty
eight thousand dollars a year but you're
destitute it's news to you I'm sure I
don't know if you take that
good or bad news but but there you go
you're destitute i-i-i know i've i've
told i've mentioned this before i but i
lived i I myself lived on 20 grand a
year for about five years in my early
20s my salary fluctuated between like
seventeen thousand I think it was I got
as high as 22 I think at one point and I
remember at one point I asked for a
raise to get up to 24 and I was turned
down and I said no you can't get the toy
but I I remember back then I used to
think if I could just make 30,000 a year
30 fell I would go to sleep dreaming of
me I really would I'd go to sleep
dreaming of what I could do with thirty
thousand dollars a year you believe it
thirty thousand a year and I never got
there at least not during that at least
not during that time okay so my point is
if 40 grand a year's destitution then
then then how did I make it on 20 grand
a year as a how did I I was I was I
I basically starve to death without
knowing it I technically in dead I don't
know if you knew this I I am technically
dead right now because I lived on half
of destitution I wasn't I didn't even
rise to the level of destitution
I was I was halfway to being destitute
on 20 grand a year and and yet even with
20 grand a year I had I had I had I had
you know I had an apartment that I lived
in I had a car I had food I even had
money left over for for beer you know
well I had to usually I had to give up
lunch so that I could so that I could
have some beer but but you got to have
your priorities and straight yeah you
know you gotta have everything in line
why the point is I was able to do that
on on 40 on 20 grand a year so 40 grand
a year is not poor it's not rich either
that's for sure but it's not poor at all
AOC is just a bloviating babbling gasbag
as usual she's basically you know what
AOC is she is basically a balloon that
when you let the air out of it that's
what AOC is
how much content is there that's how
much that's how much thought is evident
in her ideas by the way if you make
$32,000 a year if you make 32,000 so
you're not even at 38 32 that puts you
in the top one percent of all income
earner earners not in America but in the
world
you re if you make 32 or more you are a
one percenter you are in the top 1% of
all income earners which means that
according to LC even even one percenters
are destitute even most 1% are destitute
so 99% of the world is destitute by
alexandria kaiser cortezes standards and
then even probably probably like 99% of
the 1% would would would qualify as as
being poor or nearly poor so that leaves
who's left
who isn't destitute Warren Buffett I
guess Jeff Bezos Mark Zuckerberg they're
they're the only guys I guess and the
rest of us are poor this is the kind of
logic that you get from the left these
days and so you you look at their vision
of the world look at their vision of the
world everybody is poor well over 99% of
the planet is destitute human
civilization is hovering on the brink of
collapse they have come a long way from
hope and change in 2008 that's all I can
say I'm old enough to remember in 2008
when it was it was all about hope and
there's a brighter tomorrow and now
we're being told you're all dirt poor
you're gonna starve and if you don't
starve you're gonna drown when the ice
caps melting 12 years that is a very
strange form of Hope although honestly
when I see that twerking guy in DC it
kind of does give me hope to think that
we're all gonna drown in 12 years I sort
of the only thing that brings me into
despair is that it won't happen sooner
all right um just quickly I wanted to I
wanted to mention this because you might
be confused about it but there's a
there's this Joker movie coming out soon
the origin story of Joker starring
Joaquin Phoenix and I personally and you
know I'm really looking forward to it
because I love I love walking Phoenix I
think he's maybe the certainly the most
interesting actor in Hollywood maybe the
best he's great actor I'm not even a fan
of the superhero movies at all really
but I think this this looks like an
interesting movie well the movie is
generating outrage even though it's not
out yet so most people haven't seen it
it's played at some of the festivals but
it most of the people that are outraged
and concerned and worried about it most
of them have not seen it they've seen a
they've seen preview they haven't
actually seen the movie but there is
there is there is outrage and
controversy and concern over the movie
because people are worried that it's
going to encourage violence it's going
to encourage mass shootings and violence
and there's so much controversy that
Warner Brothers had to release a
statement addressing this and this is
what Warner Brothers said they said make
no mistake
neither the fictional character of Joker
nor the film is an endorsement of
real-world violence of any kind it is
not the intention of the film the
filmmakers or the studio to hold this
character up as a hero so in case you
were in case you were confused about
this alright in case you were confused
this movie about a psychotic serial
killing clown is not supposed to be a
model for your behavior in case you were
confused and I'm glad they they
clarified this because I you know
personally when I heard about this movie
the first thing I thought was you know
that actually sounds like a great idea I
think I'd like to go and commit violent
acts that's what I thought yeah we
probably most of us did I guess what we
thought you see the preview and you
think that's sad that looks great hmm
that's a good suggestion
I think I'll become a psychotic clown as
a matter of fact and I you know I was
hang on and everything I'd already got
the I got the face paint and I was I was
planning my killing spree but then I saw
this this notice from Warner Brothers
and I said oh so you're saying we
shouldn't do that all right well I mean
hopefully I can return this face paint I
did keep the receipts off to go back to
the store and say to them yeah I got a
return yeah I was gonna become a
psychotic clown but I decided not to
yeah I was good I was good at killing
yeah I was going to but I'm not anyway
can I can I get my nine dollars back so
that's just a really important important
thing there that we can all we can all
learn from
all right let's speaking of psychotic
when we have that transition you know
we're going to something good this isn't
good at all actually this is horrifying
and all I want to do is I'm gonna read a
little bit from the daily water report
and this as you will know this kind of
this story makes me livid I mean almost
blind seething with anger when I read
this stuff as it should for anyone
anyway this is the story it says more
than six more than 6,300 adults have
died from reactions to a drug that is
used as a puberty blocker in
gender-confused
children according to FDA data The
Christian Post reported on Thursday
between 2012 and June 30th of this year
the FDA documented over 40,000 adverse
reactions suffered by patients who took
Lee I'm probably gonna butcher this but
Leo Pro lied acetate lupron which is
used as a hormone blocker more than
25,000 reactions logged from 2014 to
2019 were considered serious including
six thousand three hundred and seventy
deaths Lupron is being described or
being prescribed off-label for use in
children who have been diagnosed with
gender dysphoria despite to lack a
formal FDA FDA approval for that purpose
the drug is clinically approved for
treatment of precocious
puberty a condition where children start
their pubertal process at an abnormally
early age and the blockers administered
for a short time until the proper age
Michael Laidlaw a california-based
endocrinologist who exposed an April
that doctors are giving testosterone to
gender confused girls as young as eight
years old
testosterone to eight-year-olds okay he
questioned why a physiological disorder
like gender dysphoria would be treated
with such drugs instead of proper
psychological care gender dysphoria is
not an endocrine condition but is a
psychological one and should therefore
be treated with proper psychological
care he said as highlighted by the
outlet drug sales for loop rot in the
United States in 2017 hit about six
hundred and sixty nine million dollars
as previously cut by The Daily wire
Laidlaw among other medical doctors
sounded the alarm on the increasing use
of transgender related drugs and it goes
on to talk about these these drugs being
given to people in kids children in
third and fourth grade and then anyway
you should I'm not a longer article but
you should go to Delhi wire and read the
entire report talking about the effects
even even if they're not fatal affects
the intended effects of these drugs
being given to young children and what
it does to them the ways that it dis
forms them what it does to the proper
development of the reproductive organs
of these kids because of these drugs
this is just as I said this is really
psychotic and in it in a world that made
sense a doctor who prescribed
testosterone um - to an eight-year-old
girl because she's confused and thinks
she's a boy that doctor would go to jail
for poisoning children this is you're
poisoning them this you they do not have
a physical problem that is being treated
or cured or or in any way addressed by
these drugs you are creating a physical
problem so to give someone a chemical
that creates physical problems and does
not treat any physical problem that's
poisoning is that not the definition of
poisoning somebody so in a world that
made sense
these doctors would go to jail and these
parents would lose custody of their
children and I I don't say that lightly
um you know I don't I I think taking a
child away from a parent is one of the
worst things you could do to them and it
is a it happens sometimes way it does
happen sometimes in appropriate
circumstances that happens way too often
but if you're taking your child into the
doctor to be poisoned if you're giving
hormones to your young child to stunt
their their growth and their puberty
because they're confused about who they
are and what they are and they're
confused because of you the parent you
idiot talking these parents that would
do this don't mean to call everybody an
idiot if you are a parent who would do
you are I mean an idiot would be that is
a very generous because there are a lot
of other words I can use that I'm not
gonna use here because this is a family
show sort of they're confused because of
you because you're a bad parent because
you haven't explained this to them
explain it to them it's not hard how my
my my three-year-old was he's been
saying since he was three or three years
old he was a girl cuz he's three years
old you idiot
you absolute lunatic he's three just
explain it to him he doesn't know
anything I guess we got to take him to
that to the to the doctor and have him
poisoned it's the only way what else can
we do
you are unfit you should have your pay
you should be locked in jail with your
kids taken away from you you are
destroying your kids forever you're
ruining them you realize that you are
ruining your kids you are ruining their
lives you are ruining their bodies you
are ruining their minds you are horrible
okay I just I just don't understand how
you could do this I just understand how
you do that to your child I you know how
much of a monstrous human being do you
have to be to do that to your child just
because of your own ideology in your own
you know your own delusions I don't know
yeah well we can't blame them I mean
they they really think I'd be odd well
they really think that there's that
their son is really their daughter
trapped in a boy's body and come on what
what does that mean all right
there's an airline in Japan that has
introduced a new feature to to warn you
when babies are gonna sit next to you on
a flight or at least the feature I guess
it warns you where the babies are on the
flight ahead of time so you can avoid
them so when you're booking your flight
and you're looking at the the seat map a
little icon a little picture of a baby
will pop up in the in the on the seat
chart and then you can steer clear of
that I guess is the idea and a lot of
people online seem to be approving of
this system seems to be pretty popular
as a parent of for myself I'm I'm not
offended I mean I get it
listening to a baby scream especially on
a plane is not enjoyable for anyone
though I found as a parent that I'm less
I'm I'm less sensitive to it then other
than maybe other people are who don't
have kids I get you think maybe I'd be
more sensitive to it because I got to
listen to my own kids scream and then
the last thing I wanna do is listen to
other people but when I hear other kids
screaming who aren't my kids the only
thing I think is I'm so glad that isn't
my kid especially on a plane if there's
a kid screaming it's not mine I'm just
so relieved I feel bad I have sympathy
for the parent whose kid it is and then
but also I'm very relieved that it isn't
mine and so that's why maybe I'm not as
annoyed by it but um I get it that not
everyone feels that way here's my thing
though can this logic extend beyond
babies if it's not offensive to give
warnings about babies and to single them
out and and to single parents out to by
extension then what about an icon
warning where the morbidly obese people
are sitting or where the people with
body odor or sitting or where the very
talkative people are sitting so this is
what I propose when you're buying your
ticket you should have to fill out a
survey maybe about 10 pages no big deal
covering your physical features height
weight all of that personality traits
any gastrointestinal issues you might
have
are you plung are you prone to say
flatulence on play
some people are and you put it all on
there
and this should also be enforced by law
of course and and of course if you lie
on the survey then and that's discovered
and you should be flown thrown off the
plane while it's in the air obviously
you know it goes without saying didn't
you just add it but and then we can all
game plan accordingly and we can just
and then it becomes kind of a fun
I think this Act all of a sudden now a
booking a flight becomes a lot of fun
because it's sort of a chess match of
you have to decide you see where
everybody's at and so you're making
decisions you're like okay I want to
avoid this baby over here but then
there's that going on over there and
okay but then I've got this guy over
here with body odor I've got a talkative
woman up there okay this person over
here so so then then you're just kind of
strategizing and meanwhile people are
trying to strategize around you for your
own issues and it could be a lot of fun
I you know that's an idea I think I'd
throw that out there to Delta or anyone
all right let's go to emails Matt well
show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com says and as you if you listen
to show yesterday as you're probably
expecting all of these emails have to do
with the topic of evolution so I hope
you find that topic interesting
otherwise you're gonna be bored to death
by what's about to happen here says hey
Matt this is in response to what you
said regarding the theory of evolution
in your latest episode I'm sixteen years
old and the creation/evolution debate I
think a strong case can be made for
either side not only scientifically but
also biblically I however find myself on
the young earth creation side of things
based on the research that I've done one
thing that you said in today's episode
really stood out to me there has not
been one relevant discovery to have a
significant disconfirming effect on
evolution I would like to challenge you
on that one
in 1991 dr. Mary Schweitzer discovered
soft tissue at a t-rex bone this has
been followed and then there's a link to
that article about that this has been
followed by similar discoveries and
other dinosaur species the idea that
soft tissue could survive for 65 million
years based on what we know about
fossilization is absurd this is just one
piece of evidence that I find compelling
creation.com is a good source for
similar evidences since you're a
Christian let me ask you this if God
Adam and Eve through the process of
evolution but did God look at the world
he made through millions of years of
death and suffering which evolution by
natural selection requires and see that
it was quote very good this I think
makes God a lot like or at least as
detestable as the Calvinistic God you
described in the episode prior is it not
sin that initially brought death into
the world if not and if death really is
very good how is it that you can look at
any tragedy in the world today
specifically natural disasters and say
otherwise this is not to say that you
were that where you are in the debate is
a Salvation issue or even a
theologically significant issue it's
certainly not in comparison to others
but I appreciate that you mentioned it
it's always great to hear your opinion
on things by the way the title of this
email was how could you believe in
evolution you absolute heretic and all
caps and I see now that that title was a
joke which I appreciate and I'm relieved
by especially considering I have a lot
of emails this morning with titles like
that that are not a joke and so I
appreciate that
so Ben first of all congrats on being
sixteen years old and thinking through
this stuff I think when I was 16 I could
have probably debated my favorite music
video on TRL but I would have been
useless in a debate like this
TRL you don't know anything about that
that was back in the day when the M&M TV
actually stood for music anyway so the
soft tissue and dinosaur bones that is
fascinating gives me hope for a real
life Jurassic Park one day who knows I
don't think that that has a significant
disconfirming effect at all really
because the vast majority of dinosaur
bones don't have soft tissue there's a
reason why this was a significant
discovery because never been discovered
before and there are other there are
other examples of it but it's certainly
these are minority cases you'd expect
soft tissue in a great number of them if
the earth is only six thousand years old
instead almost all of them look exactly
as you would expect for 70 million year
old bones so
let me ask you this and this isn't even
to get into any of the the the many many
problems with the idea that humans and
dinosaurs coexisted there's just no
evidence for that at all and there
should be a lot okay ie is to point to a
couple little things soft tissue if
humans and dinosaurs if humans were
walking around with t-rexes okay
and and brontosauruses and all of that
and if you are taking what appears to be
on a geological scale tens of millions
of years of dinosaur history and
condensing it and putting humans with it
and then condensing it down to what a
few thousand um there should be a lot of
evidence for that a lot and there's just
none anyway uh so let me ask you if if
the majority of the bones look like you
would expect them to look under the old
earth model which they do and a small
minority have a few aspects that you
might expect under a young earth model
which model would you say has been
confirmed okay another thing to think
about how do you know that the bones had
soft tissue
well these scientists told you right
they also tell you that the bones are 75
million years old or 65 million years
old or whatever so this is what young
earthers tend to do and I've noticed
where they reject almost all of the
discoveries and conclusions of modern
science but when any small little detail
here are there is advantageous to them
they swoop in and grab it
taking the discovery but still rejecting
the method used to obtain it that to me
seems like an invalid procedure I'm not
saying you have to accept everything a
scientist tell you I'm just saying that
you should have some logical ground for
rejecting all of it except for the bits
that happen to align with your theology
and I I don't think there are
logical grounds for it so that's my
issue in fact on the young earth model
on the young earth model you can't even
speak of fossils at all fossils but you
said yourself under the process of
fossilization we shouldn't have
we shouldn't have soft tissue okay but
you understand under your model you
can't talk about fossilization that that
that that can't that doesn't exist
fossils by definition are over ten
thousand years old by definition that's
what a fossil is that's that's part of
what makes it a fossil so the fact that
fossils exists at all is disconfirming
for the young earth model and it
certainly means that you can't prove
them too or use them to prove a young
earth when there shouldn't be any
fossils by your model on the adam and
eve bit so i guess the point there is
that you have in order to use the soft
tissue on a few of these bones as proof
of a young earth model you your talk
about picking it bones here you're
literally picking that skin off that
bone and you're tossing so many other
related things away with no logical
reason to do it other than it doesn't
fit with what you want to believe and so
that i it's just it's not it's not valid
that's that's just not logically valid
to operate that way on the mat on the
adam and eve bit god god said it's very
good yeah and that's that's a good point
but let me ask you this satan we're told
was in the garden in the form of the
snake did God mean that Satan was very
good well no okay so
no trouble with the idea that God was
referring to the good things as good and
he was not referring to the bad things
and the and the thing is you you must
believe the same thing in a young earth
or must especially if you if you if you
if they're taking it the Genesis account
completely literally and you've got the
the snake who's obviously a bad dude
trying trying to tempt Eve well he was
there apparently and he wasn't good so
we know that at least one thing has to
be excluded from that statement and then
when you factor in the you know the
existence of all of the demons and
everything then then it's really quite a
lot that's being that's not being
included in that statement of this is
very good all right this is from Jay
else as you keep claiming the Bible says
the Sun orbits around the earth the
Bible says no such thing please don't
try to support your heretical views of
Genesis by slandering God's Word
well JL unfortunately you are wrong the
Bible very certainly does indicate on a
literal reading that the Sun orbits the
earth does this mean that God was wrong
no it just means that the literal
reading was wrong and that was my point
that's my only point I'm trying to make
here that that sometimes we can think
that something is literal and then we it
turns out that it's not and sometimes
the science is what can lead us to
reevaluate something that we thought was
literal and discover that it's not and
you just can't when I say that you you
can't say oh no well we can't do that
because you're putting science above the
Bible I know you that you you can't make
that statement because that's exactly
what we did when it comes to the
heliocentric model of the universe or
the solar system rather so just one
example so let's let's establish couple
things here it's a matter of historical
record that Christians for 1500 years by
and large based primarily on a literal
reading
the Bible thought that the Sun orbits
the earth that is a matter of historical
record you can't deny it there's just
one example a quote from Martin Luther
that I'll give you he says there's a
talk of a new astrologer Copernicus
whose document who wants to prove that
the earth moves and goes around instead
of the sky the Sun the moon just as if
somebody were moving in a carriage or
ship might hold that he was sitting
still and at rest while the earth and
the trees walked and moved but that is
how things are nowadays when a man
wishes to be clever he must invent
something special and the way he does it
must needs be the best the fool wants to
turn the whole art of astronomy upside
down
however as holy scripture tells us so
did Joshua bid the Sun to stand still
and not the earth I you could find many
quotes like this from Catholics and
Protestants who believed there's just no
way that the earth goes around the Sun
because it's not consistent with the web
as for the Bible it has many verses
talking about the Sun moving across the
sky which it doesn't we move around it
now it's also true like if you're really
desperate to make these to try to make
these Bible verses still literal then
you could try to claim that well
technically though the Sun is also
moving because the whole solar system is
moving because the whole galaxy is
moving through space and and we are but
yes that's true that's not what the
Bible's saying though on a literal
reading and in it at any rate it's still
the case that we are moving around the
Sun the Sun by no means in any way is
moving around us or going up and down or
doing anything like that in relation to
the earth but on a literal reading again
that's not what it says so I could read
I mean there's the there's the the quote
from Joshua that I just put that Martin
Luther just reference so you've got that
one I don't need to read it Ecclesiastes
the Sun rises and the Sun Goes Down and
hastens to the place where it rises okay
so you've got the Sun rising and going
down and hastening clearly this is
referring on a literal reading we're
talking about it would see if you were
to read that live
really what does it mean you would
conclude that the Sun goes up and goes
down and hastens moves right around the
Earth Psalms 19 4 through 6 says yet
their voice goes out through all the
earth and their words to the end of the
world in them he has sent a tent for the
Sun which comes forth like a bridegroom
leaving his chamber and like a strong
man runs his course with joy it's rising
is from the ends of the earth that it
circuits to the end of them and there
was nothing hid from its heat and let's
see then you've got there's several
others there I'm just then you've got
you've got a bunch of stuff first
Chronicles tremble before him all the
earth yay the world stands firm never to
be moved Psalm says the world is
established it shall never be moved so
know that another Psalm says say among
the nations nations the world the Lord
reigns yay the world is established it
shall never be moved he will judge the
people's with equity okay so you got the
Sun moving up and down
you've got the Earth's not moving
staying still when if when of course we
know that the earth moves around the Sun
and you can't even say whoa no they
didn't mean the earth the globe they
meant that from the ground itself well
we know the ground moves to plate
technics tells us the ground is
constantly shifting beneath our feet so
everything is moving the earth by no
means in any sense whatsoever is still
okay so we look at that and we see that
now for us there's no problem because we
can see that okay come on Abbey this is
obviously metaphorical poetic language
we still today talk about the Sun going
up and down and rising and setting and
we don't mean it literally of course we
know that the earth is going around and
so the Sun really isn't moving in
relation to the earth but we say that
poetically metaphorically yes exactly
it's clear to us now that that's what
the how the Bible meant it
it wasn't clear for 1,500 years and it's
only clear to us because we understand
the science now and that's what makes it
clear and so
would say that it's the same thing when
it comes to the the old earth etc okay
let's see from Jordan says I wanted to
give my thoughts on the issue of
evolution versus creationism I've
studied it pretty extensively it was
taught evolution in school even on my
time at a Christian College I have two
primary reasons why I don't believe the
theory of evolution as it is presented
one is scientific the other is
theological the example you gave with
the moths was a good point my
understanding is that you would classify
those changes within species as
microevolution many dogs come from one
common set of ancestors I believe in
that and I think it's undeniable I take
issue with my macro evolution of the
gradual ascent over billions of years
from a single-celled organism into what
we see today my issue with it is the
irreducible complexities within a cell
create a statistically unachievable
chance of all coming together at once
not only that but then there would have
to be multiple cells that achieve that
improbability within the same lifespan
in order to procreate it is the
evolution from one living kind to the
next that I do not accept as provable
and reliable DNA loses information
generationally and macro-evolution would
require an addition of information to
create more complex organisms there are
many people in the scientific community
that reject the theory and they do so at
the risk of their careers I don't see
the evidence being as ironclad as you
made it seem even a 1% difference in DNA
creates an enormous gap between species
I would think it makes sense that an
upright being sharing similar traits to
humans would have this the most similar
DNA but it doesn't necessarily mean that
they both are from the same tree or that
came from that single-celled organism
theologically my issue is the evolution
requires death and suffering which
didn't enter into the world until it's a
fall of man even the New Testament
reiterated that it was from one man that
sin entered the world which brought
death unless Adam was the single-celled
organism I don't see how those work
together okay so you know I kind of
regret giving the moth example because a
lot of people have zeroed in on that and
that's not what I intended I just wanted
to give a very simple example of how an
organism might change gradually by
genetic mutation and natural selection
now yeah so put that aside that's that
was a I didn't mean for that to be the
the central centerpiece of my argument
just one small example to help visualize
how this works I think we struggle
sometimes to figure out how exactly
would this work
a change in color is a very slight
change but that's just 100-200 years on
a cosmic scale that's nothing that might
as well be five minutes hey that's
that's just nothing and I think this is
where people struggle because it's so
difficult for all of us to conceive of a
million years let alone a billion years
a change in wind color in a hundred
years is very slight but multiply that
change that degree of change which is so
so slight multiply it by a hundred
million years and then tell me what you
end up with the common ancestor between
insects and humans I believe goes back
like five hundred million years or
further so five hundred million years I
mean think about five hundred million
years human civilization about this
writing humans have only had the ability
to write for five thousand years writing
is only five thousand years old before
five thousand years ago we couldn't
write now think about five hundred
million years
okay think about how how vast in expanse
of time that really is you talk about
irreducible so so okay one other point
um
wolves you mentioned dogs dogs a better
example I should have used that rather
than moths
poodles okay so it is generally accepted
now by scientists that that as you
mentioned all dogs come from wolves they
all descend from from wolves they have
it can they have a cop they have a
common ancestor with wolves with the
modern wolf okay so it we went let's say
dogs have been domesticated for seven
thousand years in seven thousand years
we went from wolves to poodles
is it really that hard to imagine that
in seven million years we could go from
the Apes to human really dogs have been
domesticated partly for ten or fifteen
thousand years but you get my point talk
about irreducible complexity I think
that's not really a problem one example
that people often give is the I you
didn't give that example but that's a
common one I got a lot of emails talking
about the AI basically saying that you
know
you can't do anything with half an eye
so there's no way to gradually get from
no I to and I but I think or a wing is
another common example I think that's
not actually true because you can do a
lot with half an eye in half an eyes
better than no eye and if you look in
the animal kingdom and in the fossil
record you find all kinds of examples of
creatures with different stages of eye
and different stages of wing going from
blind to to sensitive to light to able
to distinguish shapes and then on and on
and up till you get to the human eye and
beyond that and you get like eagle eyes
which are better than ours same with
wings you know you've got you've got
some animals with no wings you've got
some animals that have the ability to
glide you have other animals that can
fly a little bit other animals that can
fly a lot and much higher and further
and longer and faster so so you see the
the gradation of wing the gradation of
eye and so I just don't think that
that's true as for the death before the
fall thomas aquinas among many other
theologians have said that the curse of
the fall applied to humans not animals
which makes sense when you think about
it because why should animals be
punished that seems unjust really then
why would animals be punished just
because of something an Adam and Eve did
I I so I don't think you need to
interpret it that way that there was no
animal death before the fall I think
that that is one way you could interpret
it I don't think you have to interpret
it that way especially because the
fossil record very clearly shows that
there was death before the fall and
rules it out and so that kind of helps
us I think clarify and figure out what's
going on and also you have to factor in
the distinction between physical and
spiritual death God says to Adam if you
eat the apple on that day you should die
well he doesn't die on that day as we
know why is that because he was talking
about spiritual death so there are
different forms of death as it were that
are also being referred to so I think
that helps you sort through it as well
this is from Lizzy says I thought your
segment on evolution was terribly
uninformed I really lose lost a lot of
respect for you I knew that you had been
duped into accepting the older theory
rather than the biblical account but I
had not realized that you were a
Darwinist highly disappointing there
were too many errors to count but here's
just one you said that no discovery has
disproving evolution you're wrong the K
Brehon the Cambrian explosion makes
evolution totally unworkable you need to
do more research Lizzie I got a lot of
emails about the Cambrian explosion ok
disproving evolution some ok
me ask you this Lizzy what is the
Cambrian explosion what is it say with
me
it is the sudden appearance in the
fossil record of many different animal
species 540 million years ago
that's the Cambrian explosion that's
what it is that that is what it is
so when you talk about the Cambrian
explosion that's what you're talking
about
now how could you cite as evidence for
your position in an event that disproves
your position it's amazing to me you
believe the earth is 6,000 years old the
Cambrian explosion supports me not you
but but of course you do what I said
earlier you take the bits of scientific
discovery that help you while throwing
away the very methods that were used to
discover it and discarding everything
that doesn't help you and there is no
logical system for this other than you
have your conclusion you're trying to
support and you're only gonna take the
stuff that works with it that's just
it's not a valid logical process of
evaluating this stuff so arbitrarily
this is how absurd it gets you know I'm
not trying to insult you but but you
arbitrarily you take yeah the Cambrian
explosion you take the explosion cuz you
like that
you get rid of the Cambrian part so you
want the explosion but you don't want it
in that in the Cambrian period which was
540 million years ago you can't do that
it's not it's just it's it's not fair in
an argument to do that you see it makes
the argument impossible if you're gonna
do that you got it you got to play by
logical rules so that we can have a
discussion but doing something like that
pulling the Cambrian explosion to prove
that the earth is 6,000 years old and so
I got so many emails with this and I'm
I'm stumped I'm sort of stunned by it
because it's just you're to use evidence
I mean it's it's it's almost like if
you're accused of murder and to prove
your innocence you produce the murder
weapon with your fingerprints on it it
just it's mind-boggling that's the smoke
it's literally the smoking gun that's
gonna put you away and you just
presented it like you thought it was
gonna exonerate you
the Cambrian explosion the fact that the
Cambrian period existed you're done I
mean your your whole thing is done there
so the Cambrian explosion is a big
problem for you it's not for me first of
all there this explosion happened over
this happened over the period of 20
million years so it wasn't like all at
once it was 20 million years of
evolutionary history kind of a long time
second there are other areas in the
fossil record where you have explosions
of sorts usually that marks an
extinction major extinction event that
was preceded it of which there have been
several in Earth's history third as I
said yesterday the vast majority of
life-forms do not fossil eyes for
various reasons especially especially
you know the the it takes certain
condition conditions in the earth on the
earth in the climate to facilitate and
precipitate fossilisation and so most
life forms will never fossilize and even
the ones that do most of those we're not
going to find because we're not
excavating the entire earth to find them
especially if it's buried under you know
through 2,000 feet of water or something
so forth not every species is found in
the Cambrian period some appeared later
which again points to evolution fifth
the evolutionary model does not does not
provide a full explanation for the
Cambrian explosion that's true because
it's not possible to fully explain
something that happened half a billion
years ago but the young earth model
provides no explanation for it
whatsoever because the young earth model
claims that the earth didn't exist when
it happened so that's that's the problem
you're gonna run into and I think it's a
big problem
last thing do I have okay all right one
more one more thing we'll do a real
quick this from Stephen says Matt you
put too much weight on genetics just
because we're 99% matched with chimps in
our DNA doesn't mean that we're related
couldn't God have designed us that way
separately if DNA is building block of
life and chimps look a lot like us
doesn't it make sense that they have the
same building blocks doesn't mean that
we're related yes Stephen sure God could
do it however he wants that's for sure
but but this is something that I noticed
that people do another thing that is
common is where they go well God could
have done it this way and then based on
that argument they conclude
that he did do it that way with that but
but but that kind of logic just doesn't
work because that kind of logic can
justify any conclusion by this logic you
are justified in believing anything that
is logically possible you say you can
believe that leprechauns exist on the
basis simply that God could have made
them they could exist they are possible
it is feasible so therefore they exist
you see but you can't do that what we're
asking is we're not asking what's
possible we're asking what's probable
what's what's most plausible what's most
likely based on the evidence where does
the evidence point generally speaking do
the similarities in our DNA and yes our
appearance objectively point towards a
relationship or away yes we could have
those similarities and not be related we
could that's true
but do the similarities actually
objectively point away from the
relationship so if I were to ask you why
do you think the chimps and humans
aren't related would you say well
because they look so much alike in their
DNA is 99 percent matched no you
wouldn't say that because that's not
that's that's that's something you have
to work around and explain that's that's
not evidence pointing in your direction
you must admit at least that the
physical similarities and the genetic
similarities between chimpanzees at
least are evidence in the corner of
people who pursued affirm evolution okay
so that that's something you got to deal
with it's it's not that's not in your
corner that's over here but you can't
deal with it by saying well yeah but it
could be this way that you have to give
evidence that it was that way look if if
if we want to talk about codes yeah we
look like chimps now we look
to chimpanzees but we don't God could
have done it anyway he wanted you know
and and and you say well DNA is a
building block of life so of course we
look to say well God didn't need to god
didn't even need to use DNA we could
have no DNA DNA is not logically
necessary God could have made people
anyway who wanted God didn't need to
make chimps and human beings look the
same God didn't need to make our DNA the
same God didn't need to give us DNA at
all God didn't even need to make
chimpanzees at all yet he did right and
so and he did and he also made it so
they look very similar they have very
similar genetics very similar DNA that's
how he made it and so now we have to ask
ourselves why are those similarities
there it is that we certainly have the
appearance of a relationship my
explanation for that is we have an
appearance of a relationship because we
are related so I have a very simple
explanation I have an explanation
Occam's razor I have an explanation that
doesn't really require any additional
assumptions or anything it's just why do
we look the same why does it appear like
we're related well because we are ok
simple explanation your explanation is
we don't really have one your
explanation is well you know could be
this way maybe God did it that way
because of this or that or this or that
it you get this very complex complicated
thing that you're doing leading to no
conclusion at all really and I think you
do have a serious theological problem in
that it would seem that if we are not
related and if evolution is not true
then it would seem like God certainly
made things to look like it's true and
what is God doing deceiving us it's the
same thing that young earthers do with
the with the speed of light okay well
the distant light problem for for young
earth creation is I think a devastating
problem insurmountable because we know
that the light light travels a certain
distance in a year so if we look at a
light at a star that's four light years
away we're looking for years in the past
because that light that's reaching our
eyeballs now took four years to get
there right well the problem for young
earth creationists is that we can see
stars that are millions of light years
away which means we're looking millions
of years into the past
because that's how long it took because
it took that long for the light to get
to us okay yeah we can literally look
into the past as if we have a time
machine and we can see how old the
universe is that's how that's how
scientists do it so what how do young
girls get around that well they say the
same thing they do with the chimpanzee
thing they say well I mean it could be
that light traveled faster before you
know maybe a thousands of years ago
light travelled a lot lot they would
need to travel a lot faster to make up
that distance but so maybe thousands of
years ago light travelled exponentially
faster it could be it could be that way
it's possible God could have done that
yeah he could have it is possible but
there's no reason to think that you just
just and you certainly can't get from it
could be - it definitely was without any
step in between just because it could
doesn't justify your conviction that it
definitely was that way but in order to
maintain the young earth thing you must
you must conclude based on a good you
must conclude definitely that light
traveled much faster in the past even
though there's no evidence and no real
reason to think that you see so that's
it's just again it's a it's an ill
logical process it's an invalid
illogical process that is used I think
to support a lot of these conclusions
all right that was fun I enjoyed that I
hope you enjoyed it as much as I did
and we will leave it there have a great
weekend I'll see you on Monday as long
as a baby doesn't come in between I will
see you on Monday Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 if you prefer
facts over feelings if you aren't
offended by the brutal truth if you can
still laugh at the nuttiness filling our
national news cycle well tune on into
the Ben Shapiro show or you'll get a
whole lot of that and much more
we'll see you there
[Music]